[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue à voir en direct votre
émission pour aller plus loin ce soir
sur la situation à alep la deuxième
ville syrienne s'est transformée en
piège et en tragédie humanitaire
un accord a été finalement conclu pour
les évacuations mais qui va superviser
tout cela et au delà des condamnations
et des indignations la bataille de la
paix déjà gagné par bachar al assad et
ses alliés russes et iraniens
alors quelles conséquences mon invité
sur cette actualité le spécialiste des
questions internationales
olivier ravanello le discours de
politique générale de bernard cazeneuve
le premier me s'est montré combatif et
particulièrement offensif en ligne de
mire le programme de françois fillon
retour ce soir sur ce discours sous
forme de combat électoral et sur le
projet du candidat de la droite et du
centre autour du système de santé
le débat tout à l'heure
voilà donc le programme merci de nous
suivre le hashtag au ppl pour vos
réactions et à la une ce soir la
situation à alep la bataille est en
passe d'être définitivement gagnée par
bachar al assad et ses alliés nettoyage
de la ville se poursuit on écoute sur ce
sujet le premier ministre tout à l'heure
bernard cazeneuve une tragédie
humanitaire effroyable frappe la ville
d'alep et sa population civile les
femmes et les enfants d'alep après des
mois de siège suit sous les bombes et
sont les victimes d'innombrables
atrocités selon divers témoignages
les hommes de moins de 40 ans sont
arrêtés
enrôlé de force parfois exécutés par
l'armée syrienne
avec l'appui des forces favorables au
régime de bachar al assad
à commencer par la russie
ces atrocités qui peuvent être
constitutifs de crimes de guerre voire
de crimes contre l'humanité sont
accomplies avec un cynisme et avec une
cruauté inouïe c'est l'honneur de la
france d'avoir été l'une des seules
nations a tenté de s'opposer dès l'été
2013 à la guerre totale menée par bachar
al assad contre son propre peuple
jamais nous n'accepterons au nom d'un
prétendu réalisme de nous allier
aujourd'hui avec les responsables du
martyr d'alep
je dénonce l'horreur de ces massacres et
affirme que ceux qui les ont perpétrées
auront à en rendre compte devant la
communauté internationale
il faut en parler mon invité ce soir est
journaliste spécialiste de politique
internationale
il dirige la collection tribune du monde
qui a notamment publié
ouvrage grand chambardement d'yves aubin
de la messuzière ou encore état
islamique le fait accompli de wassit
menace bonsoir et bienvenue olivier
ravanello fort pour décrire ce qui se
passe à l'aide d'abord on va entendre
les mots de du premier ministre il ya
également des phrases apocalyptique on
parle d'une nuit d'enfer celle d'hier
soir
que savons-nous plaisir de manière sûre
de l'ampleur du drame qui s'y passe de
manière sûre plus de choses et pour ma
part encore moins de choses puisqu'on
observe tout cela de très loin et que
depuis que l'étau s'est resserré sur à
l'épée clé les bombardements et la
progression de l'armée syrienne s'est
accentuée il ya assez peu de témoins il
ya des témoignages qui arrivent beaucoup
par par les réseaux sociaux par des gens
qui arrivent ils sont journalistes à
tisser un lien mais à distance avec avec
des populations civiles qui témoigne de
populations qui sont pris sous un déluge
de feu parce que l'objectif de l'armée
russe et de l'armée syriennes et de
gagner du terrain le plus vite possible
sans regarder qui se trouve évidemment
ni devant eux nue sous leurs bombes
il y à une indignation générale une
réunion d'urgence à l'onu beaucoup de
gesticulations de dénonciation au final
est ce qu'on peut dire que c'est
définitif la deuxième ville du pays est
en passe d'être reprise et que c'est une
bataille
est-ce qu'elles signent une bataille
militaires stratégiques diplomatiques de
bachar al assad mais surtout de la
russie et de l'iran
c'est plus qu'une victoire militaire
pour ce qu'on voit que les victoires
militaires depuis le début de ce conflit
peuvent évoluer
palmyre a été reprise par l'état
islamique alors qu'elle avait été
reconquis ça c'est une victoire qui est
aussi une victoire politique parce que
c'était la dernière ville où la
rébellion
je n'aime pas le mot modéré parce
qu'aujourd'hui elle est tellement large
cette rébellion que modérée ne veut rien
dire mais en tout cas que la rébellion
au régime de bachar el-assad qui n'était
pas ni al qaïda a ni l'état islamique
que cette rébellion est en train de
perdre et que c'est sans doute la
dernière ville où elle était encore
enracinée qui est en train de tomber et
que politiquement après alep
il ne restera plus sur l'échiquier que
le camp assad avec ses soutiens russes
et iraniens et de l'autre côté al qaïda
et l'état islamique et au milieu plus
rien
quand vous dites que vous n'aimez pas le
mot modéré rebellion modéré parce que
vous ne voulez pas y inclure notamment
elle n'osera ou encore el qaïda non mais
au fil de ce conflit qui dure déjà
depuis tellement longtemps
cette rébellion qui au début a été
l'émanation militaire de cette
révolution syrienne a considérablement
évolué au début vous aviez des
militaires laïcs qui ont fait sécession
et qui se sont rassemblés pour proposer
un autre régime est en effet la
communauté internationale les américains
les français et d'autres auraient pu
politiquement s'identifier et soutenir
cette partie là de la syrie qui avait
décidé de prendre les armes on ne l'a
pas fait on les a pas aidé militairement
et c'est sans doute ce qui a fait que
très vite ils ont été phagocyté par
d'autres groupes militaires qui sont
constituées dans les différentes villes
et quand vous êtes en période de guerre
il ya toujours une surenchère au plus
radicale à celui qui va aller plus loin
dans le combat dont le martyre dans le
sacrifice est évidemment ceux qui se
sont mis à se battre au nom de dieu ont
pris l'avantagé pour ces raisons là et
aussi de manière plus pragmatique c'est
parce que pour financer cette guerre
comme l'occident de finances est passé
de guerre il a fallu aller chercher de
l'argent et des armes ailleurs et que
les puissances qu'il fallait séduire
c'était le qatar c'est l arabie saoudite
et qu'il valait mieux avoir un discours
religieux très radicales pour pouvoir
obtenir leur leur grâce et
progressivement toute cette rébellion a
glissé vers l'islamisme ce qui n'était
pas fondamentalement sa vocation
aujourd'hui on ne découvre pas l'horreur
de ce qui se passe à alep
malheureusement malheureusement c'était
prévisible et tout à l'heure on écoutait
bernard cazin ville en parlait déjà au
passé c'est à dire que cette indignation
elle est sûrement sincère mais qu'est ce
qu'elle est tardive et qu'est-ce qu'elle
sonne un peu quand même
c'est surtout le signe que la france
mais les états unis et a fortiori
l'amérique de trump ne fera pas mieux
ont décidé ou en tout cas ont admis
qu'il n'y avait plus rien à faire et
qu'il ne reste donc plus que les mots et
la posture de l'indignation parce que
dans leur rapport de force diplomatique
ou dans le rapport de force militaire
des choix ont été faits qui n'étaient
pas les bons et qui font qu'aujourd'hui
la stratégie qui était celle de la
france bien est en train de déjouer et
la stratégie d'obama aussi échoue dans
des manières encore encore plus large
et l'utilisation du passé par le premier
ministre à l'assemblée était sans doute
de manière inconsciente mais très
révélateur de cela la france est qu'elle
ne peut plus rien changer
on parle beaucoup de la russie et l'iran
quand est-il aussi des autres grandes
puissances régionales je pense à la
turquie est aussi l egypte quand on dit
que le président maréchal el sissi est
aujourd'hui un soutien de bachar al
assad
il ya une chambre aux compositions de la
région et et la russie est en train de
se retisser des liens qui étaient ceux
de l'ancien empire soviétique c'est à
dire qu'elle s'appuie sur des régimes et
elle veut retisser remettre en place les
régimes qui étaient ceux des années 80
c'est à dire des régimes arabes laïcs
aligné sur moscou et c'était le cas de
l'egypte c'était le cas de la syrie pour
reconstituer son réseau d'influencé et
comme en face vous avez des états unis
qui ont abandonné le terrain obama
lorsqu'il décide de ne pas bombarder
d'assyrie envoie un signal à tout le
monde arabe et aussi à moscou te dire je
ne m'impliquerai pas eh bien si vous
laisser le champ vide d'autres
l'occupent immédiatement et c'est ce
qu'a fait la dîmière poutine et donc les
pays de la région bien se repositionne
et se repositionne face à une semi
absence américaine mais cette absence
est il donc ici possible comme de tous
va être encore plus grande dans
l'amérique de trump donc et on va
chercher un parent qui soit fort et qui
soit solide et surtout qui tient parole
parce que la grande leçon car imposé
d'ailleurs mieux la ligne jaune de
barack obama et reste dans toutes les
têtes c'est louis n'a pas eu de la part
respecté parole mais poutine a envoyé un
message à tous les dirigeants du monde
entier en leur disant si je vous dis que
je vous soutiens je vous soutiendrai
jusqu'au bout et ce qu'il fait avec
assad c'est exactement ça je ne crois
pas qu'il le soutienne au fond parce
qu'ils adhèrent complètement aux
personnages à la politique au régime
en revanche est dit au monde entier si
moi je vous soutiens vous pouvez compter
sur moi et c'est de cette manière là
aussi qui est vrai qu'il est blanc
rapport de force avec les américains ce
que vous venez de dire sur le
positionnement notamment de l'egypte
s'explique quand on vient d'apprendre à
l'instant que l'état islamique a
revendiqué l'attentât de l'église copte
du caire peut peut-être comprendre aussi
que
le président est ici d'un point de vue
religieux en tous les cas entre les
quatre veuille tourner le dos aux
islamistes quel qu'il soit même ceux qui
font partie de la rébellion en syrie oui
et il y a aussi une dynamique qui en ce
moment profite à poutine et tout le
monde le regarde en se disant sa
politique fonctionne est ce que pour
autant elle est bonne on en jugera sur
le long terme
est ce que la syrie va être gouvernable
avec assad revenu au pouvoir je ne suis
pas convaincu même assez convaincus du
contraire
tous ceux qui ont fui ce pays ne vont
pas rentrer avec la snh sur lequel vous
avez travaillé poutine que vous voyez
c'est bien absolument ainsi que la
russie mais la force de poutine
ce n'est pas qu'ils analysent mieux que
les autres dirigeants de situation c'est
qu'il a de la constance et qu'en 15 ans
au pouvoir
quand vous avez décidé d'une politique
et que vous l'appliquez le fini par
porter ses fruits ce qui aujourd'hui la
faiblesse des démocraties c'est que les
dirigeants qu'ils soient français
américains sont au pouvoir pour quatre
ou cinq ans et que face à une crise de
cette ampleur
vous ne trouvez pas la solution et vous
ne pouvez pas passer de la tentative de
règlement diplomatique à la pression
diplomatique à la pression militaire à
l'intervention militaire au règlement du
conflit en trois ans ce qui veut dire
que dans cette période là vous êtes au
pouvoir et puis vous sautez et vous
n'êtes plus au pouvoir et que d'autres
équipes arrivent la force de poutine
c'est qu'il est là il est sans doute
lent qu'en est il est là depuis 15 mai
ce qui a envoyé cette constance c'est sa
force de faire pression sur lui qu est
ce que vous pensez des sanctions qui
peuvent être reconduite comme l'a dit
françois hollande ou encore angela
merkel certains en france le réclame des
dépressions encore plus durs à son
encontre à l'encontre du pays surtout
vous ne ferez pas changé poutine d'avis
avec des sanctions mais en tout cas ça
le gêne et notamment sur son sur son
économie
tout dépend pour quoi vous voulez faire
des sanctions si vous voulez taper sur
les doigts de poutine ça ne fonctionne
pas en revanche si l'idée c'est de dire
à poutine
aujourd'hui que la russie redevenue une
grande puissance et que tout le monde le
reconnaît
et bien la responsabilité d'une grande
puissance c'est aussi de résoudre des
crises et pas simplement des amis voire
sait qu'il peut qu ils veulent
comprendre si on adoptait ce discours là
il avait déjà cédé après c'est une
question d ne l'avons pas compris c'est
une question de timing
aujourd'hui on va rentrer dans une
période où poutine aura intérêt à
apparaître comme celui qui résout les
crises il va falloir les résoudre avec
lui sinon c'est lui qui va finir par
donner le timing
au moins les cinq prochaines années
olivier ravanello au delà d'alep qu'est
ce qui se passe dans les autres villes
parce qu'il faut aussi rappeler qu'à une
guerre contre l'organisation terroriste
état islamique
on nous dit que l'état que les
djihadistes recul dans certaines villes
et on apprend qu'il reprenne palmyre
qu'elle est véritablement le rapport de
force aujourd'hui le sentiment que j'ai
c'est que toutes les forces sont en
train de s'affaiblir et que cette armée
syrienne qui va parrainer dans les rues
d'alep
de l'autre côté a perdu palmyre on parle
de front qui ne sont pas stalingrad qui
n'ont pas besoin de mobiliser des
centaines de milliers d'hommes bien
cette armée syrienne n'est pas capable
de tenir palmyre qu'elle a pourtant
repris ce qui prouve bien qu'elle est
extrêmement affaibli que cette guerre
l'a affaibli et que pour l'instant le
soutien des russes et des iraniens est
une sorte de miroir déformant où bachar
et son régime
apparaissent comme beaucoup plus fort
qu'ils ne le sont réellement mais pour
autant les russes ne vont pas pouvoir
être une force d'occupation en syrie
pendant encore très longtemps et on voit
que l'état islamique de fête et
notamment de par les bombardements qui
sont menées par la coalition depuis
longtemps est en train de s'affaiblir
que l'armée d'assad est en train de
s'affaiblir que cette rébellion
protéiforme
elle aussi est en train de s'affaiblir
et que militairement les choses ne sont
encore pas réglé et qu'il n'y a pas un
vainqueurs et des perdants et qu'on est
encore pendant longtemps dans une
période assez incertaine justement vous
l'avez dit pendant longtemps pour
conclure question difficile une science
projette un horizon moyen ou de long
terme que va représenter se pose
aujourd'hui au moyen-orient je pensais
déjà restreint pesant corps pour des
raisons tant est que comme le liban en a
souffert
ce pays frontalier qui est la syrie qui
a beaucoup de cousinage avec avec le
liban risque de s'acheminer vers le ver
le même destin
malheureusement pour les syriens merci
olivier ravanello et j'espère qu'on aura
l'occasion d'écouter vos analyses
toujours aussi pointue sur d'autres
médias peut être versée rapidement merci
encore à vous dans quelques instants
retour à présent sur l'actualité
politique en france débat sur le
discours de politique générale de
bernard cazeneuve un discours offensif
en ligne de meilleur le programme de
françois fillon dont on va également à
parler mais d'abord le tour de raison de
l'actualité du jour
[Musique]
revue d'effectif pour vincent peillon
réunion à huis clos pour l'ancien
ministre de l'éducation entouré d'une
partie de ses soutiens à la gaîté
lyrique à paris
à son arrivée il a répondu aux attaques
distillé depuis son entrée dans la
course
je dis que je veux un beau débat d'idées
vous l'avez vu pas un échange de boules
puantes
donc si certains sont un peu nerveux ya
plus de 20 ans je suis au parti
socialiste si à des cotisations à mettre
à jour les mettra à jour comme toujours
avant le vote et le dépôt des
candidatures c'est à dire je dis je le
fais avec plaisir je l'avais d'ailleurs
indiqué il ya quelques jours et puis
voilà mais vraiment j'appelle chacun je
le fais depuis un moment à faire un
débat d'idées et j'aimerais que en fasse
attention surtout qu'on est devant les
français a pas faire ce genre de chose
il va être sur une ligne socialiste qui
est là c'est ciani de la ligne 2 qu'on
souhaite à savoir c'est no 49 3 ces noms
alors les conneries et puis chez noir la
déchéance de dire c'est les valeurs du
parti socialiste
manuel valls
manuel valls lui aussi très entouré à la
maison de la chimie
l'ancien premier ministre reçoit ses
soutiens à l'abri des caméras conscient
de la concurrence que représentent
vincent peillon son équipe ne veux pas
rentrer dans une bataille des ego vous
avez quand même chic de poser des
questions j'ai pas vraiment entendu
lorsque la primaire de la droite et du
centre organisait au geipan dans du
concret dit est en tout cas à droite de
faire un qu'il faisait un concret voici
une première c'est nous qui l'avons
inventé les primaires est donc
aujourd'hui ce sont tous les soutiens de
manuel valls qui se réunissent et
c'est la seule question qu'il faut qu'on
se pose c'est pas de savoir les uns
vis-à-vis des autres invectives que l'on
pourrait avoir
c'est qu'est ce qu'on raconte en
français par rapport à ce que la droite
de mettre en place
à gauche
les députés socialistes ont un nouveau
chef olivier faure en place à la tête du
groupe bruno le roux nommé au ministère
de l'intérieur de l'ue avec 137 voix
contre 120 pour guillaume bachelay le
député de seine et marne devra amorcer
la réconciliation entre frondeur et
légitimistes al'approche de l'élection
présidentielle justice
christine lagarde bousculé par ses juges
au deuxième jour du procès de l'ex
ministre de l'économie pour négligence
dans l' affaire tapie les magistrats ont
pointé du doigt les 45 millions d'euros
versé à l'homme d'affaires au titre du
préjudice moral dans la sphère du crédit
lyonnais
l'actuelle directrice du fmi explique
avoir fait confiance à son directeur de
cabinet de l'époque stéphane richard le
pdg d'orange sera entendu demain par la
cour au sénat
[Musique]
poursuite de l'examen de la loi montagne
la couverture numérique a donné lieu à
des passes d'armes sur le niveau
d'engagement et le rôle des opérateurs
privés pour fournir l'internet à tous
ils ne viendront pas dans les zones pas
rentable vous le savez bien fait pas
semblant dans vos interventions les uns
et les autres
vous savez que c'est la conséquence de
ce qu on a votez alors maintenant qu'on
ait un débat serein raisonnable on
essaye ensemble de faire avancer les
choses
mais soyons honnête par pitié c'est la
conséquence de la privatisation
les deux derrière l'autre finances en
vue l'alourdissement de la taxe sur les
fournisseurs d'accès internet qui est
passé de 0,6 à 0,9 et qui va passer de 0
9 à 1 3 c'est à dire que la taxe a
doublé dans l'espace de deux ans laure
le l'état ne peut pas avoir un discours
un peu schizophrénique un talent
toujours plus d'opérateurs tout à leur
couper les jarrets
[Musique]
et dans l'actualité le premier ministre
a prononcé son discours de politique
générale il a obtenu d'ailleurs un large
vote de confiance de l'assemblée un
discours et une volonté pour les 5 mois
restant dans ce quinquennat
bernard cazeneuve a aussi adressé des
pics et des critiques en direction de
françois fillon et de son programme
on en débat avec nos invités ce soir
philippe dallier bonsoir sénateurs les
républicains de la seine saint denis
avec nous également l'éditorialiste
politique
hélène pilichowski bonsoir soir à vos
côtés alain richard bienvenue bonsoir à
vous en son ministre et sénateur
socialiste du val d'oise et nous
accompagne également ce soir yves derai
bonsoir vous êtes journalistes et dit
alors madame messieurs un discours de
politique générale c'est d'abord un cap
une volonté une empreinte philippe
dallier qu'est ce que vous avez retenu
de ce discours parce que beaucoup y ont
vu une sorte de tribune de combat
électoral ou politique
écoutez effectivement c'était tout sauf
un discours de politique générale mais
de toutes les manières ça ne pouvait pas
l'être puisque le budget et 2017 est en
passe d'être adopté le parlement
arrêtera ses travaux à la fin du mois de
février bon voilà bernard cazeneuve à 5
mois a passé à la tête du gouvernement
difficile pour lui j'allais dire de
d'impulser une nouvelle politique donc
effectivement il s'est servi de
l'occasion pour attaquer l'opposition
d'aujourd'hui
c'était plutôt une tribune électorale qu
un discours de politique générale oui je
suppose que c'est pas du tout votre
votre avis elle arrive ça parce que
c'est une tradition républicaine un
discours de politique générale c'est
d'abord un tcam ce même clause de la
constitution pas apprécié les
déclarations de politique générale 1
entrée en fonctions du gouvernement
bon je crois que bernard cazeneuve il a
montré la continuité la cohérence entre
l'action qui était menée par le
gouvernement auquel il a participé
que ce soit en politique extérieure
c'est comme un sujet qu'on peut pas tout
à fait balayer que ce soit en politique
économique et sociale et donc de ce
point de vue là il s'est adressé aussi à
sa majorité pour dire que vous êtes
engagés
vous avez défini nous avons défini
ressemble une action je vais essayer de
la compléter deux
de la développer encore et notamment il
à la cité d'action sur l'emploi c'est
clair que dans les mois qui reste une
des défis qu'on peut succès c'est
d'améliorer encore le corail est en cinq
mois
un diamant ça sera à 5 mois utiles et sa
région les les entreprises continuent à
investir plus on a des reconduit une
aide financière à l'investissement qui
stimule à peu et donc si les entreprises
sont en train d'investir il ya des
raisons normal de penser que ça va se
traduire par des embauches
alors quel est votre sentiment yves
derai est ce que c'est une un discours
de politique générale sous forme de
tribune électorale parce que nous sommes
également campagne électorale où est ce
que c est bien pour les 5 mois restant
un cas une volonté qui a été affirmé
aujourd'hui je pourrais donc là on a eu
affaire à un vrai discours politique ce
qui est un peu surpris dire les
observateurs parce que bernard cazeneuve
à l'image comme ça d'un homme assez
confiant suel d'un homme police
on parle de son élégance de sa
distinction de sa pochette en fait là il
a démontré que c'est un homme politique
et un vrai qui s'est attaqué à qui au
fond en priorité à françois fillon qui
aujourd'hui la figure emblématique de la
droite celui qui doit mener la droite à
la victoire et donc il se situer comme
un haut-fond le chef de la majorité
qu'il est naturellement d'être piqué
dénommé frais ministre donc je pense que
dans cette intervention voilà que je ne
sais pas s'il peut faire grand chose
pour la situation de la france mais en
tout cas pour sa situation à lui je
pense qu'il a un vrai challenge
politique parce que bien après 2017 il
faudra reconstruire sans doute la gauche
c'est un vrai challenge est là une
péniche ce qui est ce que vous pensez
que les députés que l'assemblée a voté
aujourd'hui la conférence sur un un
projet un cas c'est ça un discours de
politique générale ou alors un bilan ni
l'un ni l'autre
enfin n'ont ni l'un ni l'autre je crois
que bernard cazeneuve a bien réussi son
entrée d'ailleurs c'est quelqu'un il
faut quand même le reconnaître réussi à
peu près tout ce qui fait depuis qu'il
est arrivé au gouvernement par la petite
porte aux affaires européennes
souvenez-vous et que à l'époque il avait
une renommée vraiment tout à fait
insignifiante mais ce n'était pas
quelqu'un qui était sous les feux de
l'actualité et partout où il est passé à
l'europe il a été très présent il était
très très respecté dans les instituts
européenne puis après il est allé au
budget parce qu'ils étaient allés au
budget parce qu'il fallait remplacer au
pied levé jérôme cahuzac dans les
conditions que vous connaissez ce qui
n'était pas facile non pli s'agissait de
montrer que l'on savait tenir qu'un
ministre du budget c'était quelqu'un
quand même dans le gouvernement de
gauche
et puis après il est allé à l'intérieur
où il a fait un parcours quand même
assez tout à fait remarquable si vous
voulez franchement avec les attentats il
a été présent il a été on lui a cherché
quelques critiques plus ou moins
honnêtes d'ailleurs après l'attentât
noni souvenez vous il a affronté tous
avec beaucoup de courage est maintenant
là il y va aussi avec courage et il a
dit à une expression très aimé tenter
dit je ne suis pas là pour éteindre la
lumière
à propos des 130 jours qui va faire donc
à la tête du gouvernement
j'ai trouvé qu'il a beaucoup d'humour et
que c'est une des choses qui le
rapproche beaucoup de françois hollande
on ne dirait pas le voir comme ça avec
sodas et les bières à nîmes avec sauce
avec son allure de prélats comme ça et
bon effectivement quand on les écoute il
n'était pas très drôle cet après midi là
il n'a pas fait comme françois hollande
il n'a pas fait des petites astuces pour
détendre un peu l'atmosphère pas du tout
mais situation que nous vivons ne qu'il
a montré c'est que en cinq mois on
pouvait quand même peaufiner une action
entamée en particulier dans les secteurs
où après tout c'était pas si mal parti
que ça puisque effectivement et de l'a
rappelé il ya eu cent mille chômeurs
deux mois dans l'année donc on peut
continuer les actions qui sont menées
dalle écarquiller les yeux là mais il
faut savoir reconnaître françois
hollande a renoncé par uniquement parce
que son bilan était nul comme on l'a dit
beaucoup et presque un peu partout et un
peu trop parce qu'on ne fait plus la
part des choses
parce qu'il y avait aussi un problème un
problème de gouvernance il voulait qui
s'est installé ce qui a provoqué
effectivement d impatience par tous un
non-respect du président de la
république et puis voilà les skis le la
droite dit qu'il a été aujourd'hui
l'exécuteur testamentaire du quinquennat
de françois hollande on a eu une longue
partie du discours qui était consacrée
au bilan que françois hollande et de
cette majorité qui n'en est plus une
c'était un peu surréaliste quand même
c'est pas tout à fait ce qu'on attendait
du nouveau premier ministre
de là à dire qu'il va peaufiner la poule
on s'écoute etc etc est ce qu'il pourra
bien faire l'agenda du parlement il
connu jusqu'à la mi-février douala
jusqu'à la fin février donc on ne
modifiera un strictement rien décrets
d'application oui il ya des décrets
d'application sur quelques textes mais
ça n'aura aucun effet d'ici le mois de
mai il faut quand même se rendre à
l'évidence
donc on verra bien ce que donneront les
statistiques sur le chômage mais ce
n'est pas bernard cazeneuve qui va
jaillir changer les choses
je rappelle quand même qui nous a
déclaré ya peu de temps qu'il arrêtait
la politique au mois de juin qui ne se
représentait pas aux législatives donc
il me prépare même pas enfin moi qui ne
change d'avis mais at il pas quelque
part il n'est pas le feu il a pris un
peu de hauteur aujourd'hui
écoutez c'est un homme libre vient en
tous les cas à l'évidence ça mettait pas
un dogme libéral au sens où l'on tentera
dé majorité alain richard honnêtement à
quelle majorité il a parlé mais je veux
bien y là il a eu des discours
d'apaisement et de rassemblement envers
qui si vous deviez définir l'état de la
gauche de la majorité à laquelle il a
parlé aujourd'hui c'est pas difficile à
décrire division il ya eu des divisions
parce qu'ils avaient des divergences de
politiques notamment de politique
économique au sein de la gauche
ces divergences portaient sur ce qui
s'est passé ce qui a été décidé en 2013
et en 2014 2015
aujourd'hui on est dans une situation
qui a évolué je pense que la crise des
finances publiques
les surmonter nous serons en dessous des
3% de déficit avec une évolution
permettant de descendre en dessous de 2
indiquant que le prix murat langue c'est
de défendre je sais vous avez rendre mon
argument si vous voulez bien
et il se trouve simplement que les
institutions européennes et que la suite
de votre programme quinquennal démontre
que nous avons fait baisser simplement
des deux tiers des deux tiers le niveau
de déficit public que nous avions et
donc de ce point de vue là le pays sorte
il à faire ce qui veut dire que on a des
marches pour faire quelques actions de
progrès que nous n'avions pas il ya deux
ans et ça se voit dans le budget 2010
est et donc la majorité dont on parle
c'est la majorité qui a mené cette
action est notre objectif
naturellement ces objectifs de bernard
cazeneuve
après la renonciation du président de la
république c'est que les gens de gauche
qui ont été au gouvernement se présente
pour un nouveau mandat face à une
politique de droite qui est une vraie
politique de droite en disant vous avez
un choix
alors pas de choix je pense que ben
arcade neuf en tout cas est dans une
situation assez inédite
parce que depuis que je m'intéresse à la
boutique je me souviens pas d'une telle
situation où on a d'un côté les quinquas
du parti socialiste qui vont se déchirer
à belles dents pour essayer d'être celui
qui va reporter des couleurs du ps dans
la présidentielle
et puis de l'autre on a un président qui
a renoncé et quelque part ton qui s'est
un peu effacée et donc qu'il a un peu un
boulevard j'ai envie de dire pendant
cinq mois
s'il joue bien sa carte il peut et il en
est sans doute capable on voit déjà les
premières cerises et je peux me
rapporter au son il faut se méfier des
sondages mais il avait déjà de bonnes
enquêtes d'opinion et là je constate que
ces nominations il ya un petit effet
donc je pense que il va essayer de
profiter à fond de cette situation de
vacuité au fond du pouvoir parce
qu'aujourd'hui le pouvoir celui qu'il
incarne
c'est bernard cazeneuve oui m'enfin
tendait à partir du moment où le parti
socialiste aura désigné son candidat à
l'issue de la primaire
on sera rentré dans la campagne
électorale donc le premier ministre a
expédié les affaires courantes il n'y a
pas d'autre terme et il va être je vais
pas dire marginalisés ça serait
péjoratif mais franchement toute
l'attention des médias et les français
sera focalisée sur l'élection
présidentielle donc ne donnons pas
bernard cazeneuve un rôle qui ne pourra
pas avoir c'est bien évidemment que ça
s'est compliqué dans les affaires
courantes et j'avais effectivement et on
nous pensons ou même à la sécurité
intérieure je crois que c'est sûr je la
crois que vous êtes proche de françois
fillon tout a regardé depuis qu'il a été
donc élu à la primaire les ennuis
pleuvent quand même hein donc être élu à
la primaire demain pour
elle va s'ouvrir mais chez montebourg ça
peut être le début du championnat je dis
la même chose quand ils seront vides
est ce qu'on va en parler écouter juste
qu'on a dit justement bernard caza parce
qu'il a multiplié les piques et les
critiques envers qui bien on va françois
fillon protéger les français cela passe
aussi mesdames et messieurs les députés
par une fonction publique reconnue et
respectée proposé de supprimer des
centaines de milliers de postes et le
fonctionnaire en quelques mois c'est
remettre tout simplement en cause la
capacité de l'état à assumer ses
missions les plus élémentaires
comment en effet assurer la sécurité des
français avec moins de policiers - deux
gendarmes
comment soigner avec moins de personnel
hospitalier comment garantir l'égalité
des chances avec moins d'enseignants
comment accompagner les enfants
handicapés à l'école avec -
d'auxiliaires de vie scolaire
certes notre fonction publique doit se
réformer
il vous plait elle le fait d'ailleurs en
permanence mais je vous le dis mesdames
et messieurs les députés et je vous le
dis du fond du coeur et avec conviction
on peut réformer sans abîmer et on peut
moderniser sans détruire et cette phrase
à symbolise vraiment ce discours de
politique générale qui devient à ce
moment précis véritablement un combat
électoral et politique comme je disais
tout à l'heure ni l'un ni l'autre c'est
pas un discours de politique générale
des risques de politique générale c'est
un premier mondial est quand même plus
grands axes si tu voulais sur le plan
constitutionnel
encore qu'il n'était pas obligé de le
faire mon wagon ce nom se positionne
parmi eux aucun doute c'est pas beau qui
sans doute une question de religion
alors si vous avez un terme à
l'indicatif présent ça veut dire que
c'est une obligation c'est une
obligation coûté je respecte il l'a fait
alors il a été faire pour d'autres
c'était pas dans les faits il l'a fait
mais ce n'était pas exactement un
discours de politique générale puisqu'il
ne fait pas de grands projets puisqu'il
sait très bien qu'il n'a pas le temps de
les mettre sur pied ni deux les ennemis
de les mettre en oeuvre
mais en fait là aujourd'hui danser dans
cet aspect là qui est consistait
finalement à critiquer le la pole et les
fléchois les projets de françois fillon
c'était un discours de campagne
électorale et non pas de politique
générale ça c'est tout à fait clair des
lions se demande ce que la gauche
deviendra aujourd'hui si françois
on n'avait pas été désigné s'il n'avait
pas dévoilé son projet et signe ici une
série des doutes sur son projet et ma
question s'adresse à volants et est ce
que vous n'avez pas très honnêtement
sous-estimer cet aspect là votre
candidat est sortie largement victorieux
et vous ai dit on va rester un petit peu
tranquille sauf que quand il y à un flou
et du quotidien quand c'est flou il ya
deux mondes et martine aubry elle vous
dirais qu'il ya un loup est ce qu'il ya
un loup dans le programme jsf attendait
pour revenir sur ce que disait bernard
cazeneuve à l'entendre siens ceux ci
retrace à tout va oui mais je vais y
venir
à l'entendre tout va mieux un françois
hollande nous a même dit le 1er décembre
que les comptes publics était assainie
on a voté un budget avec 70 milliards
d'euros de déficit et personne ne croit
la prévision de croissance françois
hollande nous a dit je les réécoute et
pour être certain d'avoir bien entendu
qu'il avait préservé la dette je sais
pas s'il a utilisé ce terme là ya 2200
milliards d'euros de dettes et on est en
train de nous expliquer que tout va bien
on peut continuer comme ça encore
longtemps qu'il ne se passera rien
écouté plus personne je pense dans ce
pays ne peut croire cela
donc ce que dit françois fillon c'est
qu'effectivement il va falloir faire des
réformes qu'a faire des économies noir à
faire des économies
il les a chiffré à 100 milliards sur le
quinquennat
il a également dit cinq cent mille
emplois de fonctionnaires en moins non
pas en quelques mois mais sur le
quinquennat et si nous ne faisons pas
nous irons droit dans le mur le jour les
taux d'intérêt vont remonter et ça ne
tardera pas à arriver
voilà d'un côté on a ceux qui nous
disent regarder leur bilan il est
magnifique
il n'est pas nécessaire de faire quoi
que ce soit nous disons qu'il ya eu sur
l'assurance maladie
françois veillon ce matin dans le figaro
en disant qu'il n'était pas question de
remettre en cause l'assurance maladie
telle qu'elle existe aujourd'hui
maintenant je rappelle que la branche
santé ces 2 6 milliards de déficit
prévisionnel l'année prochaine et que là
aussi il va bien falloir faire des
économies et 4e tomber le tout c'est que
ça soit équitablement répartis c'est un
impératif mais il n'est pas question de
détricoter l'assurance maladie je crois
que mes jeux cazeneuve a pointé en fait
un problème qu'on va rencontrer
maintenant je pense quasiment à chaque
élection et qui est lié à cette affaire
de primaire c'est à dire qu'on a le
sentiment maintenant que les candidats
ils ont un programme provisoire qui est
celui des primaires donc bien ancré dans
son camp en l'occurrence bien ancrée à
droite libérale sur l'économie est très
conservateur sur les valeurs et puis
après il ya le programme présidentiel
et là ça change donc on on enjolive un
petit peu les choses on a maudit des
propositions et puis après on va voir un
troisième programme qui va être celui de
l'entre-deux tours où là il faudra
réunir une majorité donc ça devient
extrêmement compliqué et c'est vrai que
françois fillon
il est en plein dans cette ambiguïté il
a fait marche arrière et faut le dire
les choses clairement il a bien fait
d'ailleurs je pense dans cette tribune
du figaro
et je pense que sur les fonctionnaires
aussi il va bouger parce qu'on ne peut
pas se faire élire en france où il ya
cinq millions de fonctionnaires en leur
expliquant qu'ils vont travailler 39
heures payées 37 et tout ça pour
permettre la suppression de 500 mille
pages est réel ce groupe a ainsi rejoint
sa fille en a quand même et un incendie
parce que il a été acculé à le faire il
a été poussé à s'expliquer y compris
dans son camp est ce que vous pensez
aujourd'hui il a été l incendie il a pas
il a éteint une partie de l' incendie
mais en même temps il va commencer s'il
continue comme ça il va devoir continuer
comme cela
à s'offrir la réputation du cap et du
capitaine de pédalos qui fait marche
arrière et ça c'est très mauvais parce
que c'était pas l'image de fillon il est
parti sur une image d'un homme
extrêmement ferme derrière alain raîche
à ce sujet de l'assurance va l'être
montant est pilonnée l'adversaire je
n'ai pas la charte quand gérard
cazeneuve ces personnes je n'ai pas la
sûreté de soin de mon collègue d'allier
qui explique que ce que font les autres
et absolument nulle que tout est à
écraser etc
je me sens de sears annonce du matin
j'ai goûté au vrai on écoutera ensemble
enregistre un rôle entier donc moi
j'essaye de prendre les choses avec un
peu de mesure et un peu de pragmatisme
puisque c'est l'expérience qui me le dit
je crois qu'en effet le programme qui a
été fait par françois fillon était un
programme qui visait une conception que
je combats tout à fait parce que je
pense qu'on a d'autres et qu'on peut
réformer ce pays de façon beaucoup plus
mesuré et en respectant des équilibres
sociaux
et a fait des choix opposés parce que
pour l'instant on est en train de parler
de l'assurance maladie
on va se mettre à parler de la fonction
publique
il ya aussi le code du travail un léger
détail bon il est question de si j'ai
bien lu les propositions de françois
fillon d'en retirer quand même
l'essentiel les protections très bien
nous nous allons présenter quelque chose
de très différent qui n'est pas
dérisoire qui n'est pas un refus des
réformes
donc j'aimerais que vous avez accepté de
respecter les positions de vos
adversaires de ne pas les dénaturer et
je pense qu'on peut en effet continuer à
réformer ce pays
continuer à assainir ses finances
publiques sans être destructeur sait pas
quand vous dites nous vous pensez à un
candidat en particulier que vous
soutenez peut-être en quatre sets
prémery mais j'espère surtout que nous
réussirons ce que la droite a réussi
dans une primaire c'est à dire qu'à la
fin même s'il y avait des désaccords
tout le monde se réunit et je suis sûr
que non seulement manuel valls que je
soutiens a vraiment cet état d'esprit
mais s'il ya deux millions d'électeurs
qui viennent voter
je sais que eux ils viendront voter pour
dire à la fin vous réunissez et ça ça
une force alors elle est une personne
qui savait finalement projet contre
projet finalement cette élection cette
campagne présidentielle ça va être deux
visions de la vieux airs et folle c'est
à dire que le il y avait ce vieux
clivages dont on disait que les français
étaient lassés dont on disait que même
certains politiques estimaient qu'il
fallait le balayer parce que c'est ce
qui nous avait valu des alternances
parfois douloureuses on détricote à
chaque fois ce qu'ont fait les
précédents les précédents dirigeants ou
non justement de cette opposition entre
deux clubs entre deux camps alors qu'on
s'aperçoit qu'il y avait des choses qui
étaient peut-être positive c'est comme
s'ils supposons que la droite arrivée au
pouvoir au mois de mai prochain
il est évident qu'on n'est pas obligé de
rappeler que ce ne sera peut-être pas
obligé forcément ne devrait pas se
sentir obligé de détricoter tout ce qui
a été fait auparavant et qui s'est
avérée finalement positif mais cela dit
françois fillon moi je pense que
françois fillon il a établi un projet il
ya longtemps qu'ils travaillent ça fait
trois ans qu'il a commencé à travailler
sur son programme
donc il estime lui qu'il fallait un choc
salutaire à la france et quand on dit un
choc on dit des mesures dures face à
face à cette politique françois hollande
lui dit faut réformer en douceur dans sa
partie sacrée forme et en douceur c'est
quand même parfois reculés parfois à
faire passer son texte aux 49 3 parce
qu'on n'arrive pas à avoir de majorité
c'est très concret très compliqué et
finalement ce code du travail dont tout
le monde sait très bien qu'il faut qu'il
soit un petit peu allégés et ben
finalement n'a pas fait grand chose si
vous apparaître le 49-3 messi psy peut
on est en ce qui concerne ce n'est pas
sale et pas réel de dire quand même des
tricoteurs en gardant le cern la
sécurité sociale marisol touraine c'est
la rupture et franchement ça ne vient
pas
non non vous travaillez non mais je vous
en prie j'ai regardé de très près j'ai
suivi tous les débats non non attention
non mais marisol touraine par exemple se
fait fort de dire que l à sauver la
sécurité sociale que laquelle va être
bénéficiaire bon il se trouve qu'il ya
des branches qui sont bénéficiaires et
en particulier la branche retraite qui
elle faisait peser la majeure partie du
déficit sur les comptes globaux de la
sécurité sociale et il se trouve que
c'est la réforme qui a été fait en 2010
sous le gouvernement de nicolas sarkozy
qui est devenu opérante maintenant et
qui fait que le déficit a chuté de 11
milliards j'ai regardé les chiffres de
très près grâce à cette réforme des
retraites et qui a reculé l'âge de
départ à la retraite et ça probablement
que la réforme qui a été fait par par
manuel récemment par le gouvernement de
françois hollande françois hollande
portera aussi ses fruits et que la
branche et que la branche retraite
varois plus grands corps cerise
haïtienne continuer quelque chose
bon voila mais et on voit vraiment les
deux choses de manière la plus objective
possible on a quand même travaillé notre
nos dossiers email
vous dites vous avez dit est ce qu'il
n'ya pas un piège des primaires à la
fois pour la gauche et pour la droite
quand on s'adresse à un noyau dur
comment élargir après on va en parler
mais je voudrais qu'on écoute encore sur
l'assurance maladie
gérard larcher le président du sénat qui
a ses explications à lui puisqu'il a dit
assurance maladie obligatoire universel
piliers de la solidarité pivot dans le
parcours de soin la deuxième des choses
qu'il a dit il y aura pas de
déremboursement simplement ce qu'il ya
de nouveau c'est une agence de
régulation
par contre le tiers payant ça c'est sûr
c'est un choix différent et nous
n'utiliserons pas le tiers payant
donc pour moi il y avait peut-être une
correction de compréhension il ya une
clarification bas avec ces deux choses
là pour moi la faire elle est claire
elle sera assumer devant les français
voilà gérard larcher qui est également
président du comité politique les
républicains ça vous semble clair grâce
à une capitulation en rase campagne
quand même un sur cette affaire d'
agences maladie hier voilà françois
fillon avait dit assez clairement que
pour ce qui est des petites maladies la
basquaise que les médecins appellent la
bobologie et c'est bien il n'y aurait
pas de remboursement et que ce serait
les mutuelles qui prenait qui prendrait
le relais et c'est pas possible
et d'abord le se serait confiée aussi
aux médecins une responsabilité immense
de savoir quel est le rhume qui est
grave est celui qui est moins rare et
c'est jérôme chartier s'est embourbé
dans ce dossier tous ceux qui ont essayé
de plaider cette question là se sont
cassé les dents donc il fallait revenir
en arrière
il ya cette agence de régulation fois
c'est une sortie disons un peu par le
haut et d'où la question fait levier sur
le système des primaires vous avez
aujourd'hui un candidat qui a toute la
légitimité évidemment à droite et au
centre
et après est ce qu'il n'ya pas un
système vicié à savoir qu'on prépare un
programme n pendant trois ans mais qui
est pour d'abord son camp et puis après
comment j'allais dire rassembler les
français autour de ce même programme qui
était d'abord adressé à droite et au
centre
je pense d'abord que vous sous-estimez
la volonté trans fillon de réformer ce
pays
je pense que voulait sous-estimé vous
avez l'air de considérer que bon
petit à petit ce qui ces propositions
seront détricoter moi je pense que non
elles ont besoin d'être précisée ça
c'est effectivement une certitude mais
françois fillon est absolument persuadé
et c'est ce qui a fait que nombreux nous
l'avons suivi dès le départ et il est
devenu nettement majoritaires au sein de
notre camp nous pensons que ce pays a
besoin de réformes structurelles fortes
réformes structurelles qui n'ont pas été
faites mon cher collègue et ça n'est pas
c'est mon point de vue mais vous aurez
du mal à me convaincre que vous avez
fait des réformes structurelles fortes
ça n'est pas vrai on a vu comment s'est
terminée la sphère de loi de travail où
vous n'êtes pas allé au bout de ce que
vous aviez annoncé et c'est bien là
qu'est le clivage au sein de la gauche
nous pensons que la situation du pays
est grave et que nous avons le risque en
cas de remontée des taux d'intérêts
d'envoyer la france dans le mur avec ses
2200 milliards d'euros de dette
voilà pourquoi nous allons faire des
réformes forte nous les annoncerons nous
les préciseront il va falloir le faire
et nous irons au bout
soyez en convaincus alors de deux choses
l'une effectivement soit pendant la
campagne présidentielle
arrivons à convaincre une majorité
français je l'espère et je le crois
soit nous n'y arriverons pas mais nous
voulons dire les choses avant pour
pouvoir les faire dès l'été prochain
sans que les gens aient le sentiment
d'avoir été berné comme certains à
gauche ont eu le sentiment d'être bernés
par françois hollande
quand le 31 décembre 2013 il a annoncé
le tournant social libéral qui ne
figuraient pas dans sa campagne de 2012
moi je suis d'accord avec ce que vous
dites à propos de la primaire parce
qu'elle a pris merck
à quoi sert-elle au départ elle sert à
diviser le camp et c'est extraordinaire
de voir aujourd'hui les candidatures
pour la primaire de la gauche qui se
multiplient avec à chaque fois comme si
vous voulez comme comme but comme
revendiquer c'est de dire je viens pour
rassembler c'était absolument étonnant
de voir chaque nouveau candidat arrive
veut défendre son propre lancer de plus
en plus rétrécies son champ de finale
manceau gens de conviction chaque
chambre conditionne plus en plus reçu il
ya plusieurs de plusieurs défenseurs du
bilan françois hollande maintenant c'est
extraordinaire ce volet il ya plusieurs
membres de la gauche de la gauche
bon et donc on a isaf vente maintenant
c'est diviser pour rassembler mais un
qui est plus légitime pour défendre le
bilan de françois hollande c'est votre
candidat alain richard manuel valls est
ce que maintenant qu'on va connaître son
programme parce qu'il va devoir aussi
décrit
et son programme économique est-ce que
vous souhaitez un programme résolument
sociale libérale non d'une part je
voudrais revenir un instant sur la
question vous posiez c'est à dire est-ce
que forcément le résultat d'une primaire
est un programme qu'on est obligé
ensuite de corriger parce qu'il ne
correspond plus au choix qu'on veut
présenter devant les électeurs
je crois parce arbres 6,6 ravir les
candidats sérieux qui se présente pour
une primaire avec l'espoir de la gagner
et de devenir le candidat de l'ensemble
de leurs camps politiques
ils ont très bien compris ça et ils
savent très bien et je pense que
françois fillon pelé prouvé en direct le
prix politique qu'il ya à faire une
campagne avec un érythème pour la
prévert et d'en changer ensuite en plus
moi comme le disait un répit sur steam
moi je suis je crois que les français
continueront à rentrer dans l'opposition
droite gauche est en démocratie
honnêtement je préfère ça à ta les cas
en revanche s'il en sort on n'a pas de
doute lassé sinon au nom de quoi les
gens veulent très si c'était de la
combinazione donc j'ai marqué ce qui se
passe en allemagne mais j'aime bien ça
il serait difficile grotte paléolithique
discussions et ça facilite évidemment le
développement le stockage de voix
absolument improductives sur die linke
est maintenant sur la rd l'autre côté de
gens qui ne qui nous participons vient
donc moi je pense qu'il vaut mieux que
la droite soit avec un programme de
droite de préférence cohérent et que la
gauche sorte avec un programme de gauche
de préférence cohérent je ne sais pas ce
que vous appelez social libéral il me
semble que ce pays et en économie de
marché
on s'en est rendu compte voyez vous
depuis une soixantaine d'années et que
nous pensons qu'on peut rendre ce pays
plus dynamiques plus innovants et plus
capable de recréer de l'emploi sans
détruire l'essentiel des protections
c'est ça qu'on va raconter par la
plupart projet conviction quant aux
convictions candidat contre candidat il
faudra pas oublier ceux qui sont
également en dehors de la primaire eva
creusent leur sillon
vraiment merci merci beaucoup pour ce
débat et cette analyse on arrive à la
fin cette émission rendez vous bien sûr
demain à 22h avec plaisir
en quelques instants vous avez rendez
vous avec l'émission l'épreuve de vérité
présenté par michel grossiord belle fin
de soirée un truc en fait
[Musique]